Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How's everything going with you?
Everything is okay.
Cool.
Today, we're going to talk about our interests.
I like learning languages.
How many languages can you speak?
I can speak three different languages:...
...Korean, Japanese, and a little bit of English.
Wow! What about Spanish?
It's similar to English.
No. Let me master English first.
Good thinking.
What else are you interested in?
I enjoy outdoor activities like soccer.
I remember you said that before.
Do you like baseball, too?
Yes, but soccer is more exciting than baseball.
How about you?
Me? I prefer indoor activities, like reading.
Do you like watching TV?
Not really, but I do watch historical documentaries.
Like what?
"The Death of JFK."
I saw it on TV last night!
I seriously think that the CIA was involved.